hello and welcome to another episode of
science vs. the Ark Encounter today we
continue looking into the claims made by
Ken Ham and the Ark encounters Mars
exhibit there mr. ham explains why does
so many scientists reject the massive
flood on earth while accepting one on
Mars the truth is that the world wide
flood described in Genesis would
completely undermined evolutionary
beliefs about life on this planet the
rejection of the Biblical Flood is often
due to evolutionary biases rather than
the actual evidence in fact it is not a
stretch to think that nearly every
geologist would appeal to a global flood
to explain many of Earth's features if
the Bible had never mentioned such an
event is it possible that Ken Ham is
right could it really be that geologists
all around the world have joined forces
and a massive conspiracy against Ken
hams interpretation of the Bible
furthermore who were the first
geologists to realize that there is no
geological evidence of a global flood
were they evil evolutionist that hated
the Bible or did they happen to be
faithful Christians that simply cared
about the scientific process and as it
turns out actually made their
discoveries before Darwin's theory of
evolution was ever even published
meaning that Ken hams entire claim that
scientists reject the flood because of
evolutionary bye ceases well I don't
want to spoil the entire video for you
right here in the introduction so
continue watching to find out
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome back to another
episode John Perry here it seems to me
that when people talk about science and
religion especially on the Internet
oftentimes they focus strictly on the
conflicts that exist between science and
religion and that makes sense and there
are a fair amount of conflicts that do
exist but science and religion actually
have a long history of cooperation
hopefully you notice that the title of
this video series is not science versus
religion it's not science versus
Christianity it's science versus the Ark
Encounter there's just specific things
in there that are being taught that I I
think you're very dishonest and need to
be called out need to be addressed but
my hope is that this video series so far
has been something that anyone can enjoy
whether or not they are religious
professionally I have been involved in
science education now for six years and
throughout that time I've worked with a
lot of scientists in many cases we've
actually become friends and had personal
conversations we've even talked about
the topic of religion and I've been
pretty surprised to see how much
diversity of thought there is within the
scientific community about religion you
know some people are not religious at
all others are driven to do their
science because they feel that it is an
act of worship if you go back and take a
look at the history of science you will
find that this idea the idea that you
can worship God by studying nature this
has been a driving force of science
especially in the early days now when it
comes to geology historians will debate
a little bit about when exactly modern
geology first got its start but most
people will pin it back to Islam around
the Year 1000 they link it back to a man
named eben Cena and he was really
interested in mountain formations and
earthquakes he was also really
interested in Greek philosophy
particularly their concepts of logic in
the Year 1020 he wrote a famous book
called the book of healing it talks
about the importance of logic careful
inductive reasoning how to critically in
deeply examine natural phenomena and had
to conduct an experiment in it he says
the following about the
either they are the effects of upheavals
of the crust of the earth such as might
occur during a violent earthquake or
they are the effect of water which
cutting itself a new route has denuded
the valleys the strata being of
different kinds some soft some hard it
would require a long period of time for
all such changes to be accomplished in
the 1600s over in the Christian world
Nicholas steno was a Danish bishop he
spent a lot of time studying nature and
thinking about nature for him this was a
major form of worship and he's the guy
that first put forth the law of
superposition this is the law that tells
us that when you're looking at layers of
rock the layers of rock on top were laid
down most recently and the layers of
rock at the bottom are the oldest a
pretty basic concept I mean that's it's
obvious when you think about it but
nobody had ever articulated this so far
as we know until he did he also put
forth the principle of original
horizontality and what that means is
that when rock layers are laid down
they're laid down horizontally so if you
ever find rock layers that are tilted
that's because they were moved after
forming so some sort of an earthquake or
you know tectonic event moved those
rocks after they formed the work of
Nicolas Tennant really did start a
movement a lot of people started
studying geology and most of the people
at the time were clergymen and actually
you know even in like you know back in
time a little bit in the Middle Ages and
you know up to the 1800s pretty much the
only way that you could be a scientist
the only way that you could study have
free time enough to study nature is if
you were either independently wealthy or
you were a monk you lived in a monastery
and so you your cost of living was next
to zero and you had a lot of spare time
to study books translate books study
nature and so on when you read the works
of these early scientists it's really
hard to figure out where the science
starts and the religion ends
everything's blended together you know a
lot of people talk about the the issues
that Galileo had with the church but for
the most part science and religion were
buddies at that time in
the early 1800s we see the formation of
what is now regarded as the world's
oldest geological society it's the
Geological Society of London one of the
geological societies earliest and most
famous members was William Buckland and
he wrote a book in the 1820s called
observations on the organic remains
attesting to the action of a universal
deluge by deluge he means flood and he's
talking about the Noah's Ark flood in
the book he lists out what he considers
evidence for the flood including the
existence of flood gravels they're found
on pretty much every continent when a
flood happens of course it moves lots of
rocks around and those pile up and flood
gravels it's really easy to tell when
you're looking at a layer of rock that
was built up by flood and we find flood
gravel all over the world he also talks
about seashells on the tops of mountains
and so on and so forth one of the people
who read this book and loved this book
was Reverend Adam Sedgwick Reverend
Sedgwick was also a geologist he spent a
lot of time studying rock formations in
fact he eventually became the president
of the Geological Society of London and
in his early days he was completely
convinced by Buckland's book he promoted
this idea far and wide and he continued
to do so when he became president of the
Geological Society but as president of
the Geological Society it was his job to
really understand all of the research
that was going on really understand all
the discoveries that were being made and
so he dug in deep and he began to
realize all sorts of issues with
Buckland's arguments every year as
president of the Geological Society Adam
Sedgwick would give an address to the
entire society they would meet once a
year and talk about their discoveries
and in 1830 by the way all of these
talks were documented and you can read
them in 1830 he first began to publicly
hint about his doubts about the evidence
of the flood in geology he explains that
the flood gravels that we used to think
all came from one giant flood seem to
have come from multiple different local
floods instead these seashells that
we're finding on the tops of mountains
well
that's not just seashells that we find
we find entire Ecology's giant
fossilized coral reefs that could not
have grown in just one year which is how
long the Bible says that the flood
happened what this suggests it is that
those mountains actually rose up from
the seafloor
to their current state today so that was
in 1830 in 1831 which was the last year
of his presidency knowing that it was as
last year his last chance at having this
podium he just kind of let loose his
entire talk from 1831 is online you can
read it I've got a link to it in the
video description but here I'll just be
reading a few select passages some of
the most important parts so he starts
out by saying at our former anniversary
I ventured to affirm that our diluvial
gravel was probably not the result of
one but many successive periods so I was
saying you know last year I was hinting
that you know maybe the flood gravels
didn't all come from one giant flood but
what I then stated as probable opinion
may after the essays of MDB amont be now
advanced with all of the authority of
established truth so here he's saying
yeah I used to be fairly sure that the
gravels were from different time periods
but now I'm yeah I'm definitely sure
that those gravels are from different
time periods he goes on to say in
retreating where we have advanced too
far there is neither compromise of
dignity nor loss of strength for in
doing this we partake but of the common
fortune of everyone who enters in a
field of investigation like our own I
love the flowery speech of the 1800s
it's quite amusing but you know here
he's just saying you know I made a
mistake and I made that mistake publicly
but this is just the nature of science
this is what happens we come to
conclusions we find new things and
sometimes we find that our earlier
conclusions were wrong we get egg on our
face from time to time it's part of the
job bearing upon this difficult question
there is I think one great negative
conclusion now incontestably established
that the vast masses of diluvial gravel
scattered almost over the surface of the
earth do not belong to one violent and
transitory period it was indeed a most
unwarranted conclusion when we assumed
the contemporain 'ti of all the
superficial grab
on the earth so he's just reiterating
yeah it was a mistake to assume that
this was all just one thing then he goes
on to explain why he jumped to that
conclusion so easily he says we saw the
clearest traces of diluvial action of
flood action and we had in our sacred
histories the record of a general deluge
on this double testimony it was that we
gave a unity to a vast succession of
phenomena not one of which we perfectly
comprehended and under the name diluvian
classed them all together so he's saying
I got excited because I saw the gravel
and rocks and I saw the flood and the
Bible and I I jumped I jumped a gun
having been myself a believer and to the
best of my power a propagator of what I
now regard a philosophic heresy those
are some harsh words he's calling his
his previous claim that there is
geological evidence of a flood he's now
calling that philosophic heresy and
having more than once been quoted for
opinions I do not now maintain I think
it right as one of my last acts before I
quit the chair before he ends his
presidency
thus publicly to read my recantation we
ought indeed to have paused before we
first adopted the diluvian theory and
referred to all our old superficial
gravel to the action of the mosaic flood
and the part we're about to read now I
think it's really interesting because he
starts to talk about religion the
conflict between science and religion
that's starting to form here he says but
are then the facts of our science
opposed to the sacred records and do we
deny the reality of a historic deluge I
uh turley reject such an inference he
continues to say that you know in the
future people will continue to look for
signs of a giant flood he calls that
monuments of a flood and he says such
monuments at least have not yet been
found and it is not perhaps intended
that they ever should be found that last
part there is what I find most
interesting he's saying that you know
maybe we're not finding evidence of a
flood in geology because maybe the
Creator doesn't want us to have evidence
maybe the Creator wants us to you know
act on
faith after all Christianity is a
religion of faith I highly recommend
looking in the video description for the
link to this book his full talk is
really good you should read it it's
really interesting to read science back
then because as mentioned before it's
it's really difficult to tell where the
science starts and the religion ends you
don't really start to see a division
between science and religion and really
clear division between these two
different projects until scientists
branch out and start working with each
other across cultures so in England at
this time geology was pretty much just a
Christian European thing they weren't
working with Muslims they weren't
working with Hindus or Buddhists but
once these scientists started branching
out and working with researchers from
other continents and other cultures they
stopped talking about God so much
science today can be defined as the
careful collection and documentation of
observable facts and an ongoing
conversation about what those facts
might mean and because the various gods
that people believe in their religions
tend to be invisible they don't show
themselves they can't actually be
studied and discussed within the
scientific community because they're
just there's nothing there's nothing to
observe right and I imagine that unless
someone is able to find something real
something concrete that actually can be
observed science and religion will
remain separated indefinitely so
Reverend Adam Sedgwick gave that talk in
1831 Charles Darwin did not publish his
theory of evolution until 1859 now let
me be really clear scientists realize
that there is no geological evidence for
a global flood before Darwin's theory of
evolution ever existed
furthermore the people that made this
discovery they were Bible believing
Christians these are extremely well
documented facts of history now let's
see what Ken Ham has to say again this
is one of the plaques in his Mars
exhibit which we discussed on last
week's episode why do so many scientists
reject a massive flood on earth while
accepting one on Mars the truth is that
the world wide flood described in
Genesis would completely undermine
evolutionary beliefs about life on this
planet the rejection of the biblical
flood is often due to evolutionary
biases rather than the actual evidence
in fact it is not a stretch to think
that nearly every geologist would appeal
to a global flood to explain many of
Earth's features if the Bible had never
mentioned such an event so there you
have it that is the wisdom of Ken Ham I
don't think that I even have to bother
explaining and pointing out the
contradictions at this point you people
are very smart you can figure that out
if you've been watching this video
series in the first couple of videos I
showed that the exhibits produced by Ken
Ham oftentimes contradict the actual
observations that have been made in
science in the last video I pointed out
that Ken hams exhibits sometimes
contradict kin hams other exhibits and
now we see that Ken hams exhibits also
contradict really well documented
historical facts if you have been
watching this video series from the
start and you are still convinced that
Ken Ham is someone worth listening to I
really don't know what else I can say to
you honestly I don't I will continue
doing this video series I've got a
couple more videos that I want to do but
by now it should be pretty obvious
what's going on here if you happen to
have specific questions about evolution
that you would like me to answer on this
YouTube channel you can contact me on my
website at stated clearly com send me a
message let me know what question you'd
like me to address and I'm doing a
series called 113 questions about
evolution now a lot of the questions I
already have people have been asking me
questions for years but especially if I
get the same or a similar question from
multiple different people I'll address
that question right away so go ahead and
make sure that you are subscribed to my
youtube channel and feel free to leave
me messages on my website or here in the
video comments and I will try my best
to get to your questions so long for now
stay curious
[Music]